[Musique]
enfin
notre invité est médecin pour être
précis les neurologues psychiatres
éthologue et je ne saurais pas complète
si je n'ajouterai pas qu'il est
psychanalyste le fonctionnement de nos
cerveaux les mécanismes de notre mois de
notre sur moi les névroses les psychoses
tout cela n'a plus aucun secret pour lui
prenait l'idée de résilience par exemple
dont vous entendez beaucoup parler
depuis quelques années et bien c'est lui
qui l'a introduite en france et c'est un
concept qui nous a donné a tous
énormément d'espoir puisqu'il nous dit
que même après un traumatisme fort même
après la pire des épreuves nous pouvons
rebondir nous pouvons renaître nous
pouvons avancer l'histoire s'écrit
différemment mais elle sait crise quand
même et il sait de quoi il parle lui
enfants de la shoah mais sommes nous
tous capables de résilience sommes-nous
égaux devant cette idée avons nous tous
comme par instinct animal cette force
qui nous permette de renaître de nos
souffrances pose en lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue boris cyrulnik merci
d'être avec nous ici au sénat dans le
dos nous tournons est-ce qu'on est tous
capables de résilience est une question
que je me suis posée en préparant cet
entretien qui a l'air d'être un concept
universel mail est il vraiment on est
tous capables de résilience si on a un
développement correct c'est pas le cas
de tous par exemple les enfants qui ont
été isolés précocément au cours des
premiers mois les premières années de la
vie lorsqu'ils ont un trauma souffre
énormément et la résilience sera
difficile en revanche ils ont un bon
départ dans la vie s'ils ont un malheur
ce qui n'est pas rare la résidence sera
facile parce que ses enfants ou un qui
les facteurs de protection et dès qu'on
leur tend la main savent la saisir et on
peut les aider facilement est-ce que
j'ai bien défini la résilience dans mon
introduction à ce que le mot est un peu
galvaudé il est utilisé un peu à tort et
à travers on l'entend sur plein de
sujets plein de domaines et scoop
d'ailleurs ça vous agace un peu vous
qu'il avait introduit en france non non
il est utilisé dans plein de domaines
différents un bon escient quand darwin
introduit le concept de dévolution au
19e siècle ça parler de l'évolution des
moeurs l'évolution des forêts de
l'évolution des animaux
de l'évolution n'est thomis et et des
domaines totalement différent hélas la
résilience et de nouvelles évolutions
donc c'est l'évolution nouvelles des
forêts après un incendie c'est
l'évolution des moeurs après une guerre
c'est l'évolution d'une société donc non
c'est un mot qui s'applique dans
différents domaines mais qui est
pertinent est-ce que c'est pas une forme
d' instinct animal de survie
psychologique parce que de toute façon
parfois l'épreuve est tellement lourde
que s'il n'y a pas de résilience on
n'avance plus et on quitte ce monde
alors s'il n'y a pas de résidence on
arrête son développement n'est fait on
est on ne vit pas avant la mort olé il
n'y a pas de vie psychique avant la mort
alors le mot instinct on a du mal en
biologie avec ce mot parce que par
exemple on parle d'instinct maternel
or si en stress une mère elle modifie
ses comportements est-ce qu'on peut
encore parler d'instinct
si on fait ça donc si on modifie
l'environnement modifier l'expression
d'un chromosome est-ce qu'on peut encore
parler mais cela c'est un non-sujet
l'instant l'internet en cas de
traumatisme vous dites que les deux mots
clés son soutien essence alors soutient
d'abord soutien de qui de la société des
proches alors soutien quand on fait des
neuro imagerie commencer le faire
maintenant on se rend compte que quand
il ya un trauma physique le cerveau est
bouleversé mais quand il ya un trauma
psychique les hormones du stress sont
tellement intenses est tellement
importante que le sort en était un donc
ils marchent pas comme s'ils avaient un
trauma physique la première chose à
faire c'est de soutenir les gens c'est à
dire de les sécuriser ces prêts verbale
c'est je suis là on va attendre notent
une tasse de café du coup on va attendre
et quand le cerveau se remet à
fonctionner alors là il faut donner sens
à ce qui s'est passé là c'est le travail
de la parole est ce le travail de la
relation mais le soutien souvent il est
prêt verbales mais il ya des événements
tellement traumatisant qu'il est
difficile d'y donner un sens je pense
aux parents qui perdent un enfant par
exemple comment donner du sens un tel
traumatisme ça fait partie des traumas
lima enfin beaucoup ne s'en remettent
pas il n'y a pas de résidence mais si on
les laisse seuls on est sûr qu'il y aura
pas en résidence si on les soutient on
voit qu'un grand nombre de parents même
d'un des six ces situations terrifiantes
un grand nombre de parents se remettent
à vivre mais bien sûr pas comme avant et
la résilience collective vous dites
qu'elle existe qu'il ya une résilience
de groupe comment fonctionne-t-elle et
est-ce qu'elle fonctionne dans certains
groupes et pas dans d'autres et quels
sont les critères alors les sociologues
travaille beaucoup sur la résidence
collective
alors michel tousignant avec qui on a la
chance de travailler qui professeur à
montréal a trouvé une tribu d'indiens
qui avaient été chassés du guatemala par
un dictateur mais les hasards de
l'immigration font qu'une mois partie la
tribu a gardé ses rituels a gardé sa
langue est resté près des frontières et
une autre tribu a été mise d'un des
camps anonymes qui sont le pire d
accueil possible puis le groupe de
dictateur est tombé ce qu'il ya de mieux
à faire et quand les indiens sont
rentrés chez eux ceux qui avaient gardé
leurs langues et leurs traditions se
sont refait une société une cité qu'ils
ont appelée résilience 1 il ya eu très
peu de syndrome psychotraumatiques alors
que ceux qui ont été mis dans des camps
là il ya eu beaucoup de syndrome psycho
traumatiques
c'est à dire que on peut parler de
résilience de groupe si on ramène ça nos
sociétés au crise que nous vivons alors
j'ai dit renoue sociétés occidentales on
vit des crises à répétition terrorisme
c'est là aussi que le mot résidence
d'ailleurs est beaucoup apparu en france
chris qu'ovide crise climatique elles
sont majeurs et ce que vous diriez qu'on
a été résilié qu'on est résilient est ce
qu'on peut déjà le dire où est ce qu'on
le saura plus tard on le saura plus tard
parce que pour l'instant on est dans
l'affrontement on est dans la résistance
dans le coping disent les anglais on est
à la synchronie on a des problèmes à
régler aujourd'hui l'eau le lait le
virus maintenant l'ukraine les
conséquences économiques que ça va avoir
donc c'est maintenant et selon les
décisions qu'on va prendre maintenant
une grande partie d'entre nous
reprendrons un bon développement sans
oublier les preuves qu'on est en train
de subir on parlera de résidence et
certains ceux qui ont été seuls ceux qui
avaient acquis les facteurs de
vulnérabilité
avant l'épreuve de ces dernières années
ceux qui ont été abandonnés ceux là
auront du mal à reprendre un processus
de résilience et là on parlera pas on
parlera syndrome psycho traumatiques est
ce que le fait de croire en dieu
aide à la résilience le fait de croire
en un dieu aide à la résilience la
spiritualité est un précieux facteurs de
protection mais la spiritualité c'est ce
qui caractérise la condition humaine
puisqu'on est capable nous êtres humains
de se représenter quelque chose une
entité impossible à percevoir dieu où on
est capable de se représenter quelque
chose d'impossible à percevoir après
l'un après la mort
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc on est dans
la spiritualité métal physique alors que
la religion à déterminant traits
culturels si vous arrivez au monde en
egypte aujourd'hui vous avez une
probabilité de devenir musulman bien
plus grande que celle de devenir
bouddhiste donc ça veut dire que la
religion est un facteur de protection la
solidarité le sens donné à la vie c'est
la mort qui donne sens à la vie on a que
120 ans d'existence
c'est à dire que il faut absolument
qu'on vive pendant ses 120 ans pas à pas
après donc la mort donne sens à la vie
donc ça nous oblige sur les efforts à
bien se socialiser de s'adresser à la
philosophie aux oeuvres d'art la vip
renforce le fait de rêver de se projeter
est ce que là aussi ça aide à supporter
un présent qui peuvent être peut être
douloureux alors le refuge un rêve
risque d'un facteur de cette une un
facteur de protection c'est un mécanisme
de défense disait freud les enfants
malheureux les adultes malheureux quand
il rêve aussi malheureux je souffre mais
je rêve que plus tard je vais régler ce
problème je rêve que plus tard je vais
faire un beau métier où elle va revenir
où on va régler le problème alors le
raid le refuge une rêverie permet de
moins souffrir mais il faut bien un
moment il faut bien se réveiller il faut
bien se retrousser les manches furent
par ce passé une partie des rêves dans
la réalité
s'il n'ya pas résilience eux vous disais
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de vie mais
ce qu'il peut y avoir développement de
névrose je sais pas de toc des choses
que l'être humain va être développé
parce qu'il n'aura pas été capables de
résilience justement est ce que vous
faites partie par exemple de ces
médecins qui disent qu'il ya un lien
entre l'apparition d'un concert est une
épreuve mal digéré mal gérée mal mal
vécu
oui je pense que si les mécanismes de
répression laisse les gens seuls il
répète l'horreur une porte gaza sont
prisonniers du passé peuvent plus et me
fait travailler peuvent fleurir il le
voit que l'horreur de ce qui leur est
arrivé ne pense qu'à ça et ça leur
revient la nuit donc il peut même pas
récupérer la nuit qui sont prisonniers
du passé alors là il n'y a pas de
résidence même l'opposé de la résilience
est ce que le corps peut alors
éclater à la figure à cause de ça quand
on est prisonnier du passé on sécrète
les hormones les hormones du stress les
hormones du stress provoque une usure
des chromosomes non seulement ça peut
provoquer une hypertension le diabète ce
que ça provoque souvent mais en plus
sans vous on sait maintenant que les
chromosomes sont usés l'extrémité des
chromosomes est usée par le stress c'est
à dire que l'espérance de vie diminue
alors ce stress l'asu parfois il est
flagrant j'ai peur c'est nécessaire on a
besoin de stress sinon se sent pas vivre
regardez les jeunes ici se mettent à
l'épreuve tout le temps ce qu'il faut
faire d'ailleurs
et c'est le salon donne un sentiment
d'existence mais si le stress est
chronique on le voit pas venir on sait
pas pourquoi on se sent pas bien on dort
mal on est irritable et les hormones du
stress physique 16 disparus et le choeur
les vaisseaux tous les métabolismes et
l'extrémité des chromosomes et c'est
pour ça qu'on voit que dans les quatre
classes sociales difficiles houle avec
la précarité sociale
l'espérance de vie est très nettement
inférieur à ce qui arrive à organiser
une vie avec des épreuves qui
recherchent des tentes ils triomphent
les examens le métier et pourtant vous
admettrez qu'on est dans des sociétés
dans un pays où quand on a un problème
de coeur de je ne sais quoi on va nous
traiter des médicaments avec de la
chimie mais on va pas essayer des les
traités ce qui peut justement générer ce
stress on est quand même dans des
sociétés qui refusent de lier entre
l'esprit et le corps et pourtant vous
nous dites que c'est prouvé qu'un lien
très claire alors on gère avec des
médicaments parce que notre culture est
dominée par la technologie et que l'on
pense que la technologie va tour et b et
quand quelqu'un est malheureux on lui
donne des médicaments
or les médicaments certains médicaments
peuvent se permettre d'être moins
malheureux en diminuant le stress en
roman stimulant cerveau mais ça peut pas
être le fond du problème le fond du
problème c'est de réorganiser une
manière de vivre qui nous permettent de
plus déprimés ou de ne plus être stressé
et dans ce cas là c'est le sort ce c'est
à dire la compréhension si on est seul
rumine on comprend pas on rumine l'on
répète si on rencontre quelqu'un on ceux
des centres de soin il/elle jeudi elle
parce que ce - les facs et les
psychothérapeutes ces femmes
insatisfaites ici il elle nous des
centres de nous-mêmes pose les questions
font des remarques qui nous étonne et
hop on travaille et là on peut trouver
une solution alors vous vous dites que
vous n'êtes pas résilient pourtant
lorsqu'on lit votre histoire et la
carrière incroyable que vous avez eues
on se dit qu'au contraire vous incarnez
complètement le concept de résilience ce
parcours je le rappelle pour ceux qui
l'ignoreraient vous êtes né à bordeaux
en 1937 dans une famille d'immigrés
juifs d'europe de l'est votre père était
russo ukrainien votre mère polonaise ils
sont déportés tous les deux lorsque vous
avez 4 ans épreuve de votre résidence
dit toujours les orphelins sont les
seuls à avoir des parents parfaits ils
ont des mers toujours jeune toujours
belle ils ont des pères toujours gai
toujours juste c'est pas une phrase de
résilience art
oui les orphelins sont le sol avant les
parents parfaits les ce qu'ils ont dans
leurs parents boys ont des parents
fatigués on est parent justice au départ
pour dire autre chose à faire donc
chassé l'asie mais c'est bien d'avoir
des parents un parfait parce que ça nous
oblige à prendre la tolérance maman est
fatiguée n'a le droit d'être fatigué
temps en temps aussi dont j'apprends à
me des centres et de moi-même moi enfant
parce que maman est fatiguée parce que
papa était injuste donc c'est pas facile
mais c'est bien mais vous refusez
toujours de dire que vous êtes résilient
vous alors c'est un processus alors je
répondrais clairement à votre question
après l'âge de cent vingt ans dakar
quand j'aurai fait un bilan et que je
saurai si vraiment géré construit
beaucoup alors non aux fondateurs on
prend rendez vous alors
alors on va prendre rendez-vous dans 35
ans voilà
alors pour l'instant je crois que j'ai
réalisé une partie de mes rêves mais pas
tous bien sûr ça m'a coûté sa tombe pas
du ciel
j'ai donc déclenché un processus de
résidence mais c'est jamais totale mais
c'est vrai pour tout le monde ça blessé
ou pas traumatisés ou pas on a besoin de
rêve pour avoir une étoile du berger
pour se diriger dans une direction mais
on sait bien que ses rêves on réalisera
seulement partie alors vous aussi vous
allez être arrêté par la police
française dénoncé par un ami de la
famille qui vous cache vous avez alors
six ans et demi séance coûte ce qui vous
dénonce parce que vous êtes juif c'était
300 euros de récompense quand ont
dénoncé un geste important 50 euros pour
un enfant juif vous souvenez de cet
homme qui vous a dénoncé vous lui en
voulez vous avez été en colère
oui je sais qui c'est
et
je sais qui c'est parce qu'il était venu
chez marguerite farges kim chez qui
j'étais caché et et quand j'ai été
arrêté
à la synagogue de bordeaux il y avait un
officier allemand et deux tables et
j'entendais dire les adultes autour de
moi une table condamne à mort mais on
sait pas laquelle et l'officier comme
dans les mauvais films orienté vers une
table ou vers l'autre donc je savais que
j'allais on voulait me tuer c'était
facile à contrôler tout le moins à
parler autour de moi et j'ai reconnu à
ce nombre là à une table jeux reconnu
celui qui très probablement
m'avait dénoncé et quand je les ai
reconnus j'avais 6 ans et demi dont je
me suis précipité vers lui et quand il
m'a vu il a sursauté
la chasse est tombé et il est parti et
c'est là que j'ai compris que c'était
lui qui m'avait des lancers alors vous
vous allez vous enfuir 1,2 de cette
prison de ce lieu vous avez été
emprisonné par par les allemands et les
français et puis vous allez chercher à
comprendre cette barbarie la facette
très sombre de l'être humain c'est pour
ça que vous tournez vers la psychiatrie
la psychologie la psychanalyse et
l'éthologie qu'est donc l'étude des
comportements animaux est ce que
finalement vous l'avez comprise cette
barbarie oui j'ai compris que j'avais
pas compris ce qui est un grand progrès
c'est un début 10 ans c'est à dire que
non quand on n'a pas de connaissances on
a des convictions et quand on réfléchit
quand on cherche on a deux trois
connaissances et on a des questions
c'est la démarche de scientifiques on a
plus de questions que de réponses
alors danger cheminée je crois avoir
compris vers où il fallait chercher et
je crois qu'effectivement ces tragédies
social comme celle qu'on est en train de
revivre actuellement avec l'ukraine on
est tous perdants avec ce qui se passe
en ukraine tous sur la planète entière
des ukrainiens les ruches dans les pays
arabes il commence déjà à y avoir de la
famille n'y a plus de blé et nous aussi
on va payer tout le monde va payer donc
je pense que c'est y est parmi nous il
ya ceux qui dans la petite enfance au
conte des mille premiers jours avant la
parole ont acquis une estime de soi et
cela accepte le doute ils acceptent
jeunes de remettre en de se mettre en
question il accepte de changer d'opinion
dont on me dit ça mais est ce que c'est
vrai je vais les voir intel qui va me
dire autre chose donc là il ya une
démarche qui empêche de se soumettre à
l'esprit totalitaire en revanche il ya
des gens parmi nous qui c'est 30% des
enfants dans un pays en paix ses 60 70 %
des enfants dans un pays en guerre qui
ont acquis un attachement insécure ils
ont peur de tout ils n'ont pas confiance
en eux donc quand on est désorganisée au
donne le pouvoir quelqu'un de nous
sécuriser maman qui est celle qui nous
sécurise le plus les jeunes pères qui
maintenant se met à jouer aussi un rôle
de père sécurisant il participe à la
petite enfance alors qu'avant les père
était chef de famille mais il sait
jamais dans leur famille c'est les
femmes qui faisait tout et eux il était
chef mais ailleurs il était souvent à la
mise à 15 heures par jour au fond des
mines n'hésitez pas dans les familles et
cela quand ils sont en désespoir ils
sont ils capables de donner tout le
pouvoir un dictateur qui les escroquent
et là on est dans les récits totalitaire
vous avez parlé de maman de papa de
petite enfance vous faites une
transition parfaite pour ce document que
j'ai à vous proposer n'était pas le
reconnaître tout de suite c'est une
archiviste une photo de françois billoux
ancien ministre communiste de la santé
publique c'est lui qui a créé les
centres de pmi par ordonnance du 2
novembre 1945 pmi je le dis pour les
gens qui nous écoutent et qu'il ne
saurait passer le sigle pour protection
maternelle et infantile elles sont aux
noms ça être un peu oublié aujourd'hui
en tout cas ces dernières années mais
elles ont été au départ créé pour lutter
contre la mortalité infantile
aujourd'hui alors une autre fonction
d'accompagnement plutôt des mamans et
des papas c'est une invention c'est
l'invention du siècle les amy c'est une
invention merveilleuse oui le havre h ma
merveilleuse bien sûr de même que la
sécurité sociale a été inventé après la
guerre par ambroise croizat et c'est de
gaulle qui a fourni les fonctionnaires
pour en faire une institution mais c'est
ces gens l'un qui ont qui on a créé la
sécurité sociale la pmi qui métamorphose
notre manière de vivre une espérance de
vie bien plus longue un confort
d'existence bien plus lent la
possibilité de réaliser le plus qu'on
peut de nos rêves donc merci c'est
vraiment une découverte merveilleuse
mais jusqu'à la découverte de 6000 20 is
prophylaxie l'accouchement
l'espérance de vie des femmes était de
36 ans après 13 gros fès quatre enfants
arrivés à l'âge adulte c'est à dire que
les femmes donner la vie moore est très
jeune et quand elle donner la vie un
enfant sur deux mouret dans la première
année dès l'instant où la pmi ont été
mises en place ça existe encore mais ces
ports bonheur c'est ça devient très rare
les accidents les mortal il la mortalité
des enfants devient criant à la
mortalité en coût devient très rare
quand j'étais étudiant en médecine j'ai
souvent entendu la phrase c'était dans
les années 50 7 56 j'ai souvent entendu
la france monsieur choisissez la mère ou
l'enfant l'un des deux doit mourir j'ai
entendu cette phrase qu'on attend plus
que les jeunes n'en ont plus grâce à la
pmi grâce aux soins précoces ça veut
dire que les conditions très précoce
modifie non seulement l'espérance de vie
mais la qualité de vie votre intérêt
pour la petite enfance remonte aux
années 70 je crois vous avez dit un jour
vous étiez c'est un moment où vous étiez
prof d'éthologie à marseille et lors
d'une expérience où on a posé des
capteurs sur le ventre des mammifères
vous avez réussi à prouver qu'il y avait
une communication intra utérine ce qui a
été j'imagine un déclic pour vous ça a
été un moment fort et ceci à un moment
qui a été critiqué parce que
vous êtes pris des remarques du style oh
oui c'est une invention des hommes pour
empêcher les femmes d'aller travailler
alors oui c'était on avait fait avec
jacques petit on avait organisé à près
de toulon
un congrès sur qu'on a maladroitement
appelé la communication intra utérine
parce que étant éthologue et baignant
dans les milieux d'éthologie animale
je savais que chez les mammifères et
nous sommes des mammifères je savais que
chez les mammifères on est raymond
téléguidé petit hydrophones intra-utérin
après la rupture de la poche des eaux
est avancé hydrophones on disait on
appelait ça le monde du silence il ya un
barouf là dedans
déjà les bruits du coeur ya les basses
fréquences de la voix il ya un mouvement
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de bruit là de
bordeaux qu'on avait organisé ce congrès
aux embiez et dans ce congrès la
majorité des gens dans l'immédiat un
nouveau continent à explorer ce que la
commission des 1000 premiers jours
quarante ans après confirme largement et
maintenant c'est appliquer les lois
maintenant applique ces découvertes qui
ont été faites il ya 40 ans donc et on a
cessé d un nouveau monde mais une partie
des gens se sont opposés des féministes
amoureuse de margaret mitchell qui avait
dit
les hommes
les uns veulent empêcher les femmes de
travailler c'est pour ça qu'ils disent
que les maires sont importantes mais
enfants n'ont pas besoin d'affection
pour se développer
dans ça a été dit j'ai été traitée
médecin nazi parce que je en observer
les bébés comme un objet de science et
le psychanalyste qui m'a traitée de mesa
nazi a dit vous considérez les objets
comme des bébés comme des objets de
science comme le docteur mengele écrite
ça m'a fait moyennement plaisir et en
fait maintenant que au contraire les
études scientifiques permettent aux
femmes enceintes de pas mourir ou par
accident au bébé de ne pas mourir outrés
ou très peu et permettent maintenant de
concilier de constater que les bébés
sont des petites personnes en voie de
développement dans l'utérus et que la
fameuse gueule une construction du
cerveau commence pendant la grossesse
d'où la nécessité d'offrir aux femmes
enceintes une sécurité totale qu'est-ce
qui peut sécuriser une femme enceinte
son conjoint sa famille le quartier
l'inculture si une femme enceinte et
entourée par sa part ça le bébé aura
tout ce qu'il faut pour bien se
développer si c'est pas fait par exemple
on a l'exemple des petits roumain
ceausescu 170 enfants ou qui ont été
abandonnés pour une décision politique
criminelle quand les roumains auraient
organisé une niche affective sécurisante
pour les mères cent mille enfants ont
été récupérés
70000 ne déclencheront pas n'ont pas pu
déclencher un processus de résilience
parce que l' isolement avait été trop
intense trop précoce et trop durable
bresonik j'ai des photos pour vous qui
normalement sont censés vous inspirer
des choses alors celle-ci le grand
public ne comprendra pas pourquoi je
vous la présente mais je vous vois
sourire donc je sais que vous avez
compris c'est une photo du personnage
devenu mythique tarzan pourquoi je
présente parents parce que vous avez dit
que c'était votre héros quand vous étiez
tout petit et oui avec l'enfance un peu
particulière que j'ai eues j'étais très
faible j'étais très maigre très faible
physiquement
et pendant la guerre et même après la
guerre on ne pouvait espérer s'en sortir
que par les rapports de force et
quelqu'un qui n'est pas fort
physiquement moralement social normes
c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
mais c'est moins vrai aujourd'hui
mais dans les années de guerre vous des
années d'après-guerre quelqu'un qui n'a
aucune de ces trois forces a du mal à
s'en sortir donc je me disais quand je
serai grand je serai musclé comme tarzan
j'aurai un slip en peau de bête comme
tarzan j'aurai un couteau
dans ma ceinture et je serai totalement
libre bon vous avez été un peu le tarzan
de la petite enfance et une autre photo
alors celle-ci possible peut-être ne va
pas dire grand chose aux gens même à
vous même mais moi je vais vous
expliquer une photo un pont grünig matic
je fais référence à ceux à ce livre que
vous avez écrit parmi la soixantaine
d'autres livres le laboureur et les
mangeurs devant liberté intérieure et
confortable servitude pour vous il ya
deux types de personnes les laboureurs
qui acceptent le doute et cherche la
vérité et puis les mangeurs de vent qui
se complaisent dans des récits sans
fondement vous êtes un laboureur vous
bien sûr et vous aussi vous en est une
autre
parce que les laboureurs sont ceux qui
ont une connaissance enracinée c'est une
phrase d'anne heures
c'est l'excès les paysans les pêcheurs
les mères de famille elles sont une
connaissance enracinée une mère de
famille peut mettre au monde un enfant
sans connaître l'embryologie elle peut
élever un enfant sans rien connaître au
métabolisme
elle sait ce qu'il faut lui donner comme
elle sait elle s'en tient quelque chose
ne va pas l epa médecin l'epa
clinicienne elle veut pas dire ce qu'il
va peu mels et elle sent que quelque
chose ne va pas c'est une connaissance
de laboureurs et ça donc connaissance
enracinée et puis il y à ce qu'on voit
beaucoup de tout temps et qu'on voit
réapparaître actuellement on voit que
parmi nous il ya des gens qui ont une
connaissance logique cohérente déductive
est complètement délirante délirante
c'est pas forcément psychotique
aidez privatif lira le sillon que la
charrue tranchant sur le sol s'est coupé
de la réalité sensible
exemple de délire non psychotique
logique j'ai été invité en martinique et
des habits martinique et montre les
archives de l'esclave de la période de
l'esclavagé qui pèse encore lourd
aujourd'hui à martigues et ils me
montrent une archive il faut absolument
conserver l'escalavage parce que si par
malheur on le supprime le prix du sucre
20 augmenter ce qui est vrai c'est le
rique faudra payer des gens il faudra
leur offre leur apporter un logement
arrêtez de les détruire comme le faisait
les esclavages c'est vrai on a arrêté le
l'esclavagé le prix du sucre a augmenté
et ça repose sur un postulat criminels
fous
réduire privé de liberté massacrer tout
un continent pour envoyer 20 millions
d'hommes et de femmes aux états unis et
20 millions vers le maghreb dont on
parle presque pas mais dont à massacrer
pour que le prix du sucre soit moins
élevé on a massacré tout un continent et
40 millions de personnes ces criminels
et pourquoi ça repose sur ce pourquoi
des africains pourquoi il faut les
réduire en esclavage
parce qu'ils sont noirs un bon
argument sans fondement absurde qui ne
repose sur rien délire logique
une dernière question qui est en lien
avec notre lieu boris cyrulnik nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu derrière
vous il ya la sagesse ici la prudence
ici la justice derrière moi l'éloquence
c'est ce qu'il y à une de ses vertus qui
vous parle plus que les autres qui vous
caractérise plus que les autres sagesse
prudence justice éloquence leur truand
ch'nord
justice non je pense que on est toujours
forcément injuste
et éloquence parfois j'arrive à frimer
un peu le faire croire que je si
éloquent donc il reste que la sagesse
alors est-ce que ça me caractérise les
gens me le disent mais il faut pas me
croire il y en a c'est une note de
vertus que vous inventez qui n'est pas
ici merci en tout cas boris cyrulnik
d'avoir été notre invité dans un monde
un regard merci beaucoup d'or partager
votre monde est votre regard sur le
monde c'est le concept de l'émission
merci infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
et merci à vous de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur coup d'essai
[Musique]